we owned the womenís ashley tisdale is
blessing us with another tick tock video
brain finish the back story the actress
recently hit 2 million followers on the
social media app i definitely feel like
a girl boss for sure so what better way
to celebrate than to bring back her
iconic character Sharpay Evans from high
school musical
remember this scene of shar-peis
poolside number fabulous it's out with
the old in with the new well things
didn't go as fab when Ashley
accidentally hit the wrong song and
realized that wasn't her voice to the
spa our favorite part is when Ashley is
basically all of us and mouths who the f
is that
and weeding and concern ourselves with
amateurs the 34 year old captioned the
post wanted to do something special for
you guys but then realize by hey we
didn't get our Sharpay fix but at least
our girl looks good in a white bikini by
the beach this isn't the first time
Ashley channeled her inner Sharpay on
tik-tok that one's a good one when she
hit 1 million followers in January the
actress wore pink heart-shaped glasses
and took us all the way back to 2006 my
bulletin is not in my show okay
um much but maybe you can watch me play
ball sometime or something I'd rather
stick pins in my eyes well wouldn't it
be awfully uncomfortable evaporate tall
person I mean the reenactment was on
point I'd rather stick pins in my eyes
who wouldn't it be awfully uncomfortable
evaporate tall person can the girl hit
three million and redeem herself we sure
hope so in
new goodbye sounds of gray there's no
denying Ashley as a social media Queen
et spoke with her last summer where she
reveals how much fun she has making
content and I just feel like it's such a
great way to be a creator in your own
life of like what you want to put out
there and I I know my fans have been
wanting music for so long and so music
sessions was a very natural fit for my
channel
[Music]